we went just thinking about it right
but if you if you go back and you think
like what do i remember from the film i
remember
how often have you read a screenplay
where nothing happens in the first 10
minutes
no scares nothing all too often
all too often
um
i think that
because
the software now
can format things for you and everybody
learns about final draft or or
movie magic or whatever they learn about
these these different
programs
it's easy to make your screenplay look
professional it's only when you
start to read it do you do you
understand
the level of craft that they're at right
now
right and in certain levels of craft
there's always that oh we're building to
something great we're building to
something great and that's at a certain
level right
and they may be
really you know really good at crafting
a story and dialogue and
things may seem okay
but if nothing is happening
and nothing is happening by page 10
nothing is happening by page 15 but page
20 when is something gonna happen
i do i do read a lot of scripts where i
wonder that or i wonder what is the
point
what is the point what are you trying to
say
even if you have nothing to say
what is the point of the film
who's your hero what is this person
going through
how does going through this change them
how does going through this and them
changing
help them deal with the true protect uh
antagonist
you know all those things all those
questions they aren't answered because
they aren't at that level yet
you know
so
you're gonna get a mismatch but for the
most part i would say out of
if i read
10 screenplays
something happens by page 10
in one of them depending upon which week
it is
not every time does something happen
not all the time does it
sometimes it might be one out of 20
screenplays
what if someone says well i want to take
my time with the suspense i mean if you
look back at the stepford wives and i
realize that's not really horror it's
more like thriller
it was a long intro
to them coming to this new neighborhood
and seeing these wives and
and she's kind of confused about what's
going on i mean it took its time yeah
but the thing about it is it establishes
its tone very quickly
and i feel like that's another thing
that's missing because
so many people haven't found their voice
how they tell a story right
because your story may change depending
upon
whatever genre you've decided to write
today whatever got into you like
this love story that i wanted that i'm
writing right now moon in the stars it's
it's a it's people hear me say it's a
love story and you think oh romantic
drama and i'm like actually no it's a
sci-fi is sci-fi these people are uh
interstellar travelers interdimensional
travelers time travelers and they can do
this and they can do that and like but
then where's the love portion well the
love portions here and it's but it's a
completely different thing than i've
ever written
once in one is a very completely
different story than i've ever written i
think that people classify that one as a
suspense drama or drama thriller or
something like that
so and that's very different than the
horror that i've directed and even
within the horror i've directed many
different types of horror
so
no matter what the genre is that you're
writing in you have to at some point
have developed your voice
and how
how how a person recognizes that it's
your film
right
and then once you start to develop your
voice i think it'll help you drastically
with maintaining tone of a film
because your voice is your voice and
it's how you tell the story and as long
as you understand the tone of your own
film you can keep that modulated all the
way through and you can set that at the
very beginning then once you set that
tone like this is where this story takes
place in this type of world
you start that from page one
you start it from page one
so yes
nothing may happen in terms of
someone getting murdered or whatever you
may not get the horror in the because it
may not be a horror maybe it's just a
movie that's meant to make you squirm
and make you uncomfortable
maybe that's what it is or maybe the
story is speaking to um like with once
and one it was about a guy who didn't
even know himself anymore so if he
doesn't know himself he doesn't even
recognize himself in certain situations
and if you tell him he's done something
wrong
he's relying on your truth to tell him
he's done something wrong because he
doesn't even know right and wrong of
himself anymore and i showed that from
page one
if you can't even recognize
who you are and what you do in the
situation when someone tells you to make
it better how can you he's like how do i
how do i do it and the person has to
tell him i think that's something you
can figure out and he's like
i don't think he can
he really can't it sets the tone for the
film nobody died
you know
nobody was hunted down in the first 10
pages i just set the tone for for what
the story is
and i think that that's
you know once you it takes a while
before you get to that level of
understanding of of what you're doing
and then i think
now you've gotten to a point where
technically you're proficient
you know but you still have so much more
like so many more levels to climb
you know
do you think it's better that someone
rushes into
a more of a horrific scene or takes
their time like which which is more
detrimental to a horror script too long
to get into the action or too fast
i mean again i i think it depends on the
the point of the story
i think that
scream which is
one of my faves from the 90s
it in the first film
it kind of meanders right at first
in the first like minute or two she
picks up the phone she's talking to the
guy
and making popcorn everything seems fine
it seems very casual
it's not until the first kind of slip up
that she doesn't hear that we heard is
the audience that we realize wait a
minute and then you start to
you start to sit forward right
the story is about a guy
who calls you on the phone he stabs you
to death
we didn't see that until like it came in
probably around the five-minute mark is
when we started to be concerned
right
so in that first five minutes it's like
are we just following this lady and if
you notice that movie is
really for the longest time it's a
single shot
it's a single shot she picks up the
phone and they pull away from the phone
they're following her around into the
kitchen it's a single shot for a lot of
it
and even when they
abandon it they pick it up on another
another wonder and they're walking
around
and it's masterfully done
but it's all about the pacing and the
tone
and it slowly becomes more menacing
and once it becomes menacing it never
lets up
and so again less about dialogue and
more about camera movement camera
movement and just
really understanding tone i think you
know lighting
plays an incredible cinematography in
general plays an incredible uh role in
creating tone your cinematography your
editing post-production sound musical
cues sound effect all that stuff plays a
huge role in it but when you're reading
it on the page when you're on the page
it has something has to set the tone for
me to understand
why i should care
and a lot of the times i ask
why should i care very early i'll ask
that on page sometimes too i'll ask why
should i care now something may not
happen until page three or page four but
i'll be asking myself why do i care when
i watch movies at home i'll turn them on
i'll watch for a little bit but then
i'll turn it because there's so much
content that's available right now
why would i waste time i treat a movie
that i'm watching just like i would a
script that i'm reading i start watching
and if it's not catching my attention i
have to abandon
i have to abandon it
i think it was harder before because
there was so little you couldn't check a
phone
you couldn't have one window open and be
over here you had to you were just like
all right i'll let it play
and sometimes that worked with advantage
because then it grew on you but now
you have to catch people that's what i
was asking if you knew the analytics of
when people dropped out or if people
rewound a scene or something yeah i
don't have it like in terms of analytics
from from
amazon i don't have it when someone
maybe
rewinds it or something i don't have
that but i do know
i can tell
the progression like
people are dropping out dropping out
dropping out dropping out oh it
stabilized and then people watched it
all the way through here and then it
dropped out like i can tell that you
know but i can't really tell
did they pause it and then go do
something and come back like i can't
tell those sort of things or that they
rewind you can't really see that
but
the thing about it is is that i usually
will start my films
and i try to get them to a point where
you don't
feel there's a place to jump off because
something's always building to something
else
and one scene leads into the next very
naturally so i'm constantly trying to do
that so it doesn't feel like there's a
place to really drop off or you'll feel
like you're missing something because
something just happened so now i have to
see how that affects the next thing i'm
constantly trying to to keep that
momentum going and i think that's what
you you have to do or what you should
aspire to do
when you're doing anything
something it always has to be building
towards something or what else are we
doing
why would i be investing my time if if
nothing in your script is investing
towards something bigger
so a bigger character goal or a bigger
scare or or something with the
antagonist
yeah set up your stakes
um
give me a character who's who's
interesting that i care about
um even if you don't want to root for
them to succeed root for them to not
succeed something give the audience
something to to to
to keep them invested and keep them
interested and
it does start with having something in
the first few pages whether it's tone
whether it's an act of whatever that
drives the story forward give them
something that keeps them
watching more importantly something that
lets them know what kind of a ride
they're on sure because even with
hereditary we didn't totally know we
just knew something ominous
yes was there and it kind of keeps you
on the edge
and you didn't know what was it though
you know yeah and the great thing about
hereditary right now is if if you if we
talk about hereditary the first thing we
do is go you know hereditary you know we
went just thinking about it right
but if you if you go back and you think
like what do i remember from the film i
remember
there was this like little sibling thing
with the brother and the sister i
remember her head hit that pole
and it came off
and then i remember he didn't want to
like he just parked the car and went
into the house
i remember the thing from him in the
classroom where his face kind of you
know went crazy and he slammed his head
on the desk and stuff i remember that
and then i remember all the stuff that
happened at the end with him
you know with the mother and the father
bursting into flames and all that stuff
and the mom banging her head
but we're recalling just these few
moments but the fact is
is that we made it to the end in
complete terror because of the tone of
the film
the tone was set very early and they
never let up
even when they had moments where it
looked like hope was starting to shine
in through the window
it didn't matter the tone was so dark
and ominous and heavy that you just you
felt like oh and you felt cold i don't
know if anybody i felt cold watching it
you know it was it was such a weird
feeling that you got watching that movie
but they kept that tone up throughout
the entire film and that's what i mean
is it's finding your tone and staying
with it very early something that makes
people care and make them keep watching